[Música]
salud en directo américa más romeros
alaya conmigo en el estudio mar a
bienvenida feliz lunes feliz inicio de
semana vamos a hablar hoy entonces de
los trabajadores del ámbito sanitario y
la vacunación contra el kobe 19 el
impacto al virus en todo este personal
de los centros de salud mar si llevamos
un año de pandemia un año y medio
durísimo para todas estas personas
entonces está bueno que nos centremos
también en cómo están ellos y quién
mejor para hablar de esto que el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
doctor empecemos para hablar de todas
esas reticencias que hay en una mínima
parte de la comunidad médica todavía a
vacunarse contra el cob y 19a que esta
vacuna sea obligatoria cuéntenos cuál es
el impacto que obtendría para la
sociedad que todos estos médicos y
personales sanitario se vacune contra el
virus
es muy importante recordar que la
vacunación no es solamente una
protección individual sino una acción
colectiva eso que significa que en los
trabadores de la salud no es solamente
la protección de la salud del trabajador
sino de su entorno y principalmente los
pacientes que están en su cuidado
entonces una política de seguridad del
paciente que es algo que la organización
mundial de la salud impulsa es que los
trabadores del sur protejamos a los
pacientes y la vacunación nuevamente
repito no es solamente por el trabajador
sino para que los pacientes a nuestro
cuidado no se enferme ahora doctor la
vacunación también como usted lo dice es
para proteger a los médicos como
impactado el kobe 19 a ustedes los
trabajadores de la salud
raúl en el primera fase la pandemia pues
fue terrible porque era la primera línea
y la que está enfrentada a una
enfermedad que no se conocía con el
atendimiento de las vacunas lo que hemos
visto es una reducción muy importante en
el nombre del caso sin mortalidad a
pesar de haber atendido las olas
subsecuentes de la pandemia ha sido
menos en impacto las través de la salud
pero ya tienen otros fenómenos no como
el agotamiento la salud física y mental
porque estar al frente de pacientes con
kobe con todos los elementos de
protección personal más todo el impacto
social que trae estar en este ambiente
pues ha hecho que haya en merma en la
salud en otros aspectos pero
afortunadamente las vacunas para
nosotros han sido una clave para poder
seguir adelante atendiendo los pacientes
en estas olas y recordemos de hecho que
la organización mundial de la salud
descifraba como en 117.000 más o menos
los muertos entre la comunidad médica a
raíz del cobi 19 pero apartemos un
momento este virus porque también hay
otros efectos hay otras vacunas que sean
obligatorias para como médico o como
personal sanitario
sí y yo creo que la vacuna debe ser
parte de esta obligatoriedad nosotros
los médicos nos tenemos que vacunar para
hepatitis b cuando estamos en
entrenamiento para varicela tenemos que
tener refuerzos y de anticuerpos para
sangre para el sarampión para directoria
es decir que los trabajadores sanitarios
tenemos que tener esquema de vacunación
para proteger nuestra salud pero también
muy importante para proteger a los que
cuidamos y esta vacuna de joven va a ser
parte muy seguramente ese esquema una
acción obligatorio que todos los
trabajos sanitarios debemos hacer
y que estamos haciendo con las vacunas
que actualmente nos colocamos para ser
médicos enfermeras laboratoristas
etcétera ahora doctor le pregunto qué
tipo de enfermedades afectan normalmente
en el ámbito laboral de la salud
los trabajadores sanitarios estamos
expuestos a lo que se llama digamos como
cualquier trabajador a todo lo que
sucede en una empresa pero especialmente
lo que se llama el riesgo biológico que
es el estar en contacto con secreciones
sangre que pueden afectar la salud del
trabajador de la salud por ejemplo por
un pinchazo o por un contacto inadecuado
o una secreción que se infecta ante ese
riesgo biológico es el que tanto nos
preocupa y por eso los elementos de
protección personal algunas vacunas nos
protegen para eso como la hepatitis b
pero por ejemplo un trabajo de la salud
se expone al vih cuando atiende a
pacientes con esta enfermedad o a un
tema es también de alta transmisibilidad
por eso el trabajador de la salud que ha
sido hoy una roca en la atención del coi
19 son referentes en el cuidado de la
salud y debemos
mostrar ese respeto y seguir ese ejemplo
del cuidado en desarrollo de su trabajo
pues doctor muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa nos
vemos en un próximo programa también
marc muchísimas gracias a por todas
información y pues toda la conversación
que tuvimos con él